der ausbruch ist stand heute wieder
beherrschbaren beherrschbarer geworden
die einschränkungen wegen corona zeigen
wirkung
für eine entwarnung ist es
gesundheitsminister sparen aber noch zu
früh
massiver wirtschaftseinbruch in china
zum ersten mal seit jahrzehnten
schrumpft die wirtschaft der
volksrepublik leere bänke
stadtgemeinschaft in der krise vertreter
der religionen arbeiten an konzepten für
gottesdienste trotz grüner
die nachrichten des tages heute mit
petra gerster guten abend wir kommen bei
den 19 uhr nachrichten am freitag und
auch heute können wir verhalten positiv
beginnen
denn die entwicklung der korona
infektion in deutschland lässt aufatmen
auch wenn dies erst der anfang der
pandemie sei wie der präsident des
robert koch-instituts heute sagt und
gesundheitsminister sparen betont dass
deutschland im internationalen vergleich
gut da steht
wir hatten beschränkungen der letzten
wochen hätten sich offensichtlich
gelohnt
das zeigt sich zum beispiel bei der
sogenannten re produktionszahl die liegt
jetzt mit 0,7 unter 1 das heißt
infizierte stecken weniger menschen an
außerdem gibt es momentan keine engpässe
bei der behandlung allerdings erkrankt
immer mehr medizinisches personal und
die zahl der toten stieg zuletzt
besonders stark vertreten wiedemeier
über die aktuelle bilanz
gesundheitsminister jens spahn hatte
heute positive nachrichten zu verkünden
die bisherigen maßnahmen der regierung
seien erfolgreich man habe ein wirklich
gutes zwischenergebnis erreicht haben es
geschafft das dynamische wachstum
zurückzubringen zu einem linearen
wachstum die infektionszahlen sind
deutlich gesunken vor allem auch die
relativen steigerung von tag zu tag der
ausbruch ist stand heute wieder
beherrschbaren beherrschbarer geworden
das gesundheitssystem sei derzeit nicht
überfordert es gebe keine engpässe
daher müssten auch nicht mehr alle
intensivbetten freigehalten werden
verschobene operationen könnten jetzt
nachgeholt werden so dass wir dann ab
mai denke ich schrittweise eben auch
eine neue normalität im klinikbetrieb
kommen können bei dem wir eine bestimmte
zahl der intensivbetten und der betten
in den krankenhäusern weiterhin
verhalten
für kidd 19 behandlungen die sogenannte
reproduktions zahl ist auf 0,7 gesunken
ein infizierter steckt nun rein
rechnerisch weniger als einen menschen
an
aber fakt ist auch es infizieren sich
immer noch mehr als 3000 menschen
täglich mit dem corona virus auch die
todeszahlen
nehmen zu und wir sehen auch dass immer
mehr menschen die in medizinischen
einrichtungen tätig sind erkranken
der anteil hat sich zum beispiel
gegenüber der vorwoche um rund sechs
prozent erhöht er liegt insgesamt bei
rund 5 prozent von den gesamten
meldezahlen um einen weiteren anstieg zu
verhindern soll vermehrt getestet werden
und auch die klinische prüfung eines
impfstoffes läuft demnächst in
deutschland an
bei der bewältigung der krone epidemie
schneidet deutschland im internationalen
vergleich gut ab
das macht uns demütig aber nicht
übermütig denn es gebe keine garantie
dass die infektionsquelle weiter
abflachen
deswegen würden die kontakt beschränkung
auch nur vorsichtig gelockert trotz
einiger erfreulicher zahlen
neben dem robert koch institut ermittelt
die us amerikanische
johns-hopkins-universität wichtige
zahlen zur pandemie schauen wir jetzt
wie jeden tag darauf wie sie für
deutschland aussehen
stand 18 uhr 30 sind laut john hopkins
und johns hopkins universität 138 1456
infektion durch tests bestätigt davon
gelten 81 1800 menschen als genesen 4193
starben in verbindung mit cupid 19
wann und vor allem wie einschränkungen
im täglichen leben wieder zurückgefahren
werden können das ist in vielen
bereichen noch unklar
für kindertagesstätten haben sich bund
und länder heute auf leitlinien geeinigt
zunächst wollen die bundesländer die
notbetreuung bis zum dritten mal
ausbauen
jedes für sich eine einheitliche
regelung wird es nicht geben
für die zeit danach wollen bund und
länder aber gemeinsam erarbeiten wie die
kita ist wieder schrittweise öffnen
können
stillstand in deutschland mit massiven
folgen auch für handel und industrie und
angesichts von vorsichtigen optimismus
im kampf gegen korona macht die
wirtschaft druck auf die politik die
forderung beim spitzengespräch mit
wirtschaftsminister altmaier heißt
planungssicherheit
armin coerper beginnt seinen beitrag mit
einer großen kaufhaus kette die
dabei sein will wenn die ersten läden
wieder öffnen
80 millionen euro kostet der shutter und
karstadt kaufhof jede woche sagt das
unternehmen und zieht gegen das land
nordrhein westfalen vor gericht
verständnis kommt vom handelsverband hde
für den angeschlagenen kaufhaus riesen
bei kaufhof caster die gerade in einer
historischen restrukturierungen sind die
haben natürlich wesentlich mehr
betroffenheit als ein kleinerer händler
der das möglicherweise auch noch wieder
aufholen kann aber auch hier ganz klar
gesagt es gibt gott sein dank den
rechts- wie auch das thema als der
wirtschaftsminister heute die
spitzenverbände aus industrie und handel
zur video konferenz trifft viele der
korona verordnungen finden die schwer
durchschaubar ausnahmen oft nicht
nachvollziehbar
wir werden die fehler und die
unzulänglichkeiten die es geben mag an
der einen oder anderen stelle auch
weiterhin korrigieren und dafür sorgen
dass lücken geschlossen
besonders die gastronomie klagt über
perspektivlosigkeit die 800 quadratmeter
regelungen für den einzelhandel
erscheint vielen willkürlich die
verbände kritisieren
planungsunsicherheit mich sorgt ein
wenig dass sich die vorbereitung der
politik zum neustart in 14 tagespläne
schöpfen könnte der minister verspricht
wir werden in den nächsten wochen auch
dafür sorgen dass die deutsche
wirtschaft sich besser darauf einstellen
kann
dass die produkte produktionsprozesse
hochgefahren werden die verkaufsprozesse
hochgefahren werden viele unternehmen in
deutschland fürchten nicht um einbußen
sondern um ihre existenz peter altmaier
hat heute klagen angehört aber auch
gekonnt hat in höhe und geschwindigkeit
der hilfspakete seit deutschland
weltweit führend
frank bethmann an der frankfurter börse
für handel und industrie ist es ja nicht
gerade einfach wenn jedes bundesland
selbst entscheidet wie und wann es die
zügel gelockert oder wieder anzieht
ja in der tat das ganze ist ein
flickenteppich und speziell für den
handel ganz schwierig zu bewältigen
die dahinterstehende logistik muss
wieder komplett hochgefahren werden egal
ob alle oder nur ein paar wenige läden
wieder öffnen dürfen
zudem hat der handel ganz
unterschiedliche gesichter der
verbandspräsident sprach vorhin von
spannungen innerhalb der branche und
spitze ist so lebensmittel gegen
modehäuser die derzeit richtig gut
verdienen gegenüber denen die täglich
millionen verlieren oder in zahlen der
gesamte handel in deutschland
beschäftigt drei millionen menschen
davon sind 1,7 millionen derzeit ohne
tätigkeit eben weil die geschäfte zu
sind oder nur teilweise geöffnet werden
das zeigt schon die ganze problematik so
schnell die bundesregierung am anfang
mit rettungs milliarden geholfen hat so
schwer ist es jetzt das richtige maß zu
finden um die wirtschaft wieder ins
laufen zu bringen
der teufel steckt eben im detail vielen
dank für ihre einschätzung frank
bethmann an der frankfurter börse
massive folgen für die deutsche
wirtschaft hat vor allem auch die lage
in china
und da kannten die wirtschaftsdaten sehr
lange zeit nur eine richtung immer
weiter nach oben wie der blick auf das
bruttoinlandsprodukt zeigt jetzt zum
ersten mal seit jahrzehnten schrumpft
die chinesische wirtschaft im ersten
quartal 2020 ist das
bruttoinlandsprodukt um 6,8 prozent
gegenüber dem vorjahr eingebrochen
der stillstand nach dem virus ausbruch
hat china enorm zugesetzt
aus peking stefanie schöneborn es sind
die schlechtesten wirtschaftszahlen seit
40 jahren die china heute verkünden
musste
schon vor der korona krise ging das
wachstum zurück doch mit der pandemie
ist die wirtschaft in china jetzt
eingebrochen
zwei wochen soll das
bruttoinlandsprodukt betrug im ersten
quartal 28 88 millionen euro ein
rückgang von 6,8 prozent im vergleich zu
den zahlen aus dem vorjahr der
chinesische wirtschaftsexperte wang
chung geht davon aus dass china sich
davon so schnell nicht erholen wird
die wirtschaftliche wachstumsrate für
das ganze jahr wird meiner meinung nach
bei drei bis fünf prozent liegen
das heißt die wirtschaftliche
entwicklung wird nicht so optimistisch
seien wie zuvor eingeschätzt
das hat auswirkungen auf deutschland und
europa auch wenn die großen firmen in
china ihren betrieb teilweise schon
wieder aufgenommen haben die pandemie
hat die ganze welt erfasst
die nachfrage wird erstmal
zusammenklappen zu einem teil wir haben
im servicesektor immer noch eine ganz
starke rezession hier für europäische
formen und natürlich in dem herstellende
gewerbe wollen wir natürlich dass china
schneller wächst das land versucht schon
jetzt mit steuersenkungen und sonder
anleihen gegenzusteuern
doch auch china muss noch weiter gegen
das virus ankämpfen die angst vor einer
zweiten infektionswelle lockert auch die
engen kontrollmaßnahmen nicht in china
und somit wohl auch für den rest der
welt wird es wirtschaftlich für firmen
und menschen weiter zu gehen
von der chinesischen millionenstadt uwe
hahn verbreitete sich das corona virus
jahr rund um den globus dort sind
allerdings deutlich mehr menschen
gestorben als bisher gemeldet wurde
die behörden korrigierten die zahl der
todesfälle auf 3896 das sind 50 prozent
mehr als vorher
die zahlen aus china waren von experten
immer wieder angezweifelt worden
kritisch ist die lage in großbritannien
fast 14.000 menschen sind bisher in
verbindung mit dem virus gestorben die
zahl dürfte aber noch sehr viel höher
sein denn sterbefälle in alten und
pflegeheimen und zu hause sind in der
statistik nicht enthalten
die strengen ausgangssperren geld noch
mindestens drei wochen andreas stamm
über ein weiteres land im krisenmodus
eine schleife für jeden toten der
vergangenen wochen es sind so viele mehr
als normal
der ärztliche leiter eines altenheims in
nordengland will ein zeichen setzen für
die die in der korona krise in
britannien mehr oder weniger vergessen
würden menschen im pflegeheim für die
mitarbeiter ist es ganz schrecklich ich
habe im irak gedient und gerade erst zu
einem örtlichen hausarzt gesagt ich wäre
lieber wieder im krieg als das hier
mitmachen zu müssen
nur ein winziger bruchteil der
altenpfleger wurde bislang getestet das
öffne dem virus tür und tor
tests für bewohner ebenfalls mangelware
genauso wie schutzausrüstungen fürs
personal
britische medien berichten dass
totenscheine nicht korrekt ausgestellt
werden tausende tote in heimen wurden
bislang vermutlich nicht erfasst der
gesundheitsminister verspricht abhilfe
mehr tests mehr masken kittel brillen
was er eigentlich seit wochen tut wenn
es um die krankenhäuser des landes geht
das ziel das sind 100.000 es täglich bis
ende april die realität aktuell 18.000
in sachen schutzbekleidung für ärzte und
pfleger leistet der minister am morgen
gar eine art offenbarungseid
ich würde gerne einen zauberstab
schwingen und es würden
schutzausrüstungen in mengen vom himmel
fallen
dann könnte ich ihre frage beantworten
wann der mangel daran beseitigt sein
wird britische luxusmodemarken die
barmer oder burberry nähen jetzt
schutzkleidung nach wochen der korona
krise wirkt in großbritannien immer noch
vieles improvisiert zu langsam
auch deshalb warnen experten es drohen
bis sommer 40.000 corona tote in die usa
auch dort wird der geeignete zeitpunkt
gesucht die einschränkungen im kampf
gegen die pandemie zu lockern
us-präsident trump hat dabei vor allem
eins im blick dass die wirtschaft ins
laufen kommt der mit einer boomenden
wirtschaft wollte er im wahljahr punkten
über trumps plan ines trams aus
washington wenn es nach präsident trump
geht sollte das land zügig zum alltag
zurückkehren
das santa cruz county in kalifornien
setzt das um ein paar stunden nach
trumps presseauftritt öffnet es seine
strände die menschen zwiegespalten
ich bin so aufgeregt ich kann es nicht
abwarten in den ozean zu springen ich
liebe es ich sorge mich etwas ich werde
hier nicht bleiben wenn es voll wird
zuvor hatte präsident trump empfehlungen
vorgelegt mit denen das land
schrittweise start für start zum alltag
zurückkehren kann
wir starten wieder unser leben wir
beginnen die verjüngung unserer
wirtschaft und zwar auf sichere und
strukturierte weise ein fahrplan zurück
zur normalität dort wo ausreichend
getestet wird und wo die
infektionszahlen zurückgehen sollen nach
und nach geschäfte und schulen öffnen
reisen wieder erlaubt sein hatte trump
zuvor behauptet er habe die
weisungsbefugnis will er nun den
zeitplan den gouverneuren der
bundesstaaten überlassen wie aber sollen
die wissen wann die infektionen
zurückgehen denn noch immer wird nicht
ausreichend getestet washington lässt
viele staaten hier hängen
der präsident will nicht glauben dass
das testen ein problem darstellt und es
ist insbesondere dann ein problem wenn
wir das land wieder hochfahren wollen
krank will das land öffnen doch die
verantwortung dafür überlässt er den
gouverneuren sie haben den schwarzen
peter wenn schief geht zurück nach
deutschland und einer wichtigen
nachricht für arbeitnehmer
krankschreibung per telefon mit dieser
ausnahmeregelung ist es nämlich wieder
vorbei wer atemwegsbeschwerden hat muss
ab montag wieder zu einem arzt und sich
untersuchen lassen
die große mehrheit derer die sich mit
dem corona virus infizieren haben ja
glücklicherweise nur relativ milde
symptome jeder fünfte aber erkrankt
schwer meist mit einer gefährlichen
lungenentzündung und akuter atemnot
in solchen fällen werden patienten
künstlich beatmet das kann leben retten
ist aber nicht ohne risiko
heute haben deutsche lungenfachärzte
bilanz gezogen
heike kruse berichtet die gute nachricht
in deutschland kann momentan jeder
corona patient angemessen behandelt
werden immerhin 20 prozent erkrankten
schwer
fünf davon müssen auf die
intensivstation so heute die erste
bilanz der fachärzte füllungen
krankheiten
sie warnen davor das virus unterschätzen
oft verschlechtere sich das
krankheitsbild sehr schnell
verhält sich etwas anders als wir das
bisher weil so schweren lungen
schädigungen könnten entsprechend müssen
wir auch die beatmung darauf einstellen
bei schweren entzündungen können die
kleinen lungenbläschen kollabieren oder
mit sigrid verstopfen
der austausch zwischen blut und atemluft
ist stark gestört
die lunge beginnt flüssigkeit
einzulagern den patienten fällt es immer
schwerer selbst luft zu holen
über einen beatmungsschlauch kann ein
luft sauerstoff gemisch mit überdruck in
die lungen gebracht werden
die lungenbläschen werden offen gehalten
und der gasaustausch verbessert sich das
auspusten mit druck von außen in die
lunge hinein ist eigentlich etwas völlig
natürliches und kann die lunge
zusätzlich schädigen
deswegen muss man das immer so schonend
wie möglich machen das am besten so
machen dass die eigene atem
anstrengungen des patienten nur
unterstützt wird durch die maschine für
nicht zu schwer erkrankte menschen
reicht oft eine atemmaske andere müssen
aber über wochen mit dem atem schlauch
unter narkose beatmet werden bis es
einen impfstoff gibt ist die künstliche
beatmung die wichtigste hilfe für
schwerkranke corona patienten welche
menschen sind besonders gefährdet und
gehören zur risikogruppe
damit beschäftigt sich ein zdf spezial
gleich nach uns und in unserer zdf heute
app finden sie neben einem live blog
berichte über die korona krise aus
deutschland und anderen ländern
in zeiten wie diesen sind aber nicht nur
ärzte und politiker gefragt gerade auch
das bedürfnis nach seelischem zuspruch
ist groß
orte wo menschen solchen beistand suchen
sind zum beispiel gotteshäuser ob
christlich jüdisch oder islamisch doch
die sind derzeit geschlossen weil gerade
da sich menschen nahe kommen zu nahe
heute gab es ein gespräch zwischen den
religionsvertretern und der
bundesregierung peter theisen
der pfarrer ganz allein in der kirche
dass dekan klaus nebel in der osterzeit
gottesdiensten uhr per livestream zu den
gläubigen bringen darf das schmerzt und
die menschen haben schon eine große
sehnsucht verständlicherweise auch eben
wieder zum gebet zusammen zu kommen und
es ist nicht nachvollziehbar warum man
am bau marktstart schlange stehen kann
aber nicht in die kirche gehen kann
bisher trugen die gemeinden alle
einschränkungen mit doch dass die nun
verkündeten lockerungen für autohäuser
und kleine geschäfte gelten nicht aber
für gotteshäuser
das stößt auf unverständnis es gibt
leute denen die suchen trost
das kriegen sie auch zur zeit nicht das
fehlt mir schon ein bisschen ja und halt
auch die gemeinschaft die kirchen ließen
sich viel einfallen gottesdienste im
internet bis hin zu drive-in messen im
autokino
doch nun drängen sie darauf wieder in
echter gemeinschaft zu beten
es handelt sich hier um ein grundrecht
das durch die verfassung geschützt ist
und wir sind nicht irgendein kulturelles
oder ein ökonomisches angebot das wir
hier machen sondern wie gesagt es geht
um ein grundrecht das elementar ist für
unsere freiheitliche gesellschaft wir
haben uns in den letzten wochen schon
intensiv gedanken darum gemacht wie wir
menschen schützen können die in den
kirchen gottesdienst feiern
es geht dabei natürlich wie soll es auch
um abstand um möglichst großen abstand
insbesondere wenn es um das singen geht
unter strengen auflagen sollen
gottesdienste wohl spätestens ab anfang
mai wieder möglich sein
in sachsen sogar schon ab kommender
woche und auch in moscheen und synagogen
darf bald wieder gemeinsam gebetet
werden
rund ein halbes jahr nach den tödlichen
angriffen in halle hat der
generalbundesanwalt anklage gegen den
attentäter erhoben
der zur tatzeit 27 jährige hatte am
höchsten jüdischen feiertag jom kippur
vergeblich versucht mit waffen eine
vollbesetzte synagoge zu stürmen
danach erschoss er eine passantin und in
einem nahegelegenen döner imbiss einen
mann
andere opfer wurden verletzt der
attentäter hatte alles gefilmt und im
internet übertragen
journalist durch und durch mit markanten
schnauzer und markanten meinungen ulrich
kienzle ist gestorben
zdf chefredakteur peter frey würdigte
ihn als profunden kenner des nahen
ostens kinzel berichtete aus vielen
arabischen ländern seit 1990 für das zdf
ein interview mit dem irakischen
diktator saddam hussein ein
zeitgeschichtliches dokument millionen
zuschauer kennen kinder aus dem
politmagazin frontal polarisierend und
witzig seine streitgespräche mit bodo
hauser fragen kienzle die ja hause 200
folgen von tal wann ist eigentlich
schluss
ulrich kienzle wurde 83 jahre alt
leben mit der korona pandemie für uns
seit vielen wochen alltag für drei
raumfahrer eine ganz neue erfahrung nach
mehr als 200 tagen auf der iss landeten
die drei in der steppe kasachstans der
empfang unter strengen schutzmaßnahmen
wegen corona eines machten die
raumfahrer aber klar trotz allem sehe
die erde von dort oben genauso
atemberaubend aus wie immer und was das
wetter betrifft auch bei uns auf der
erde die sonne strahlt weiter um die
wette wie gleich katja hornuf er
verspricht so viel von uns für den
moment schön dass sie dabei waren
das heute journal mit marietta slomka
heute um viertel nach zehn und wir sind
morgen wieder für sie da punkt 19 uhr
schönen abend noch
[Musik]
guten abend meine damen und herren sehr
kühl blieb bis heute hier an der ostsee
mit nur elf grad sommerlich warm wurde
es dagegen am oberrhein mit 26 grad und
dazu gab es immer wieder kleinere
quellwolken die brachten aber so gut wie
keine regenschauer mit und das wird
jetzt auch in der nacht der fall sein
deswegen ist die nacht meist klar da
wird es kalt bei minus zwei bis plus
fünf grad im nordosten milder bleibt die
nacht im süden und morgen gibt es dann
erstmal viel sonnenschein für uns alle
am nachmittag können sich dann aber
durchaus im westen und im süden einzelne
kurze regenschauer und gewitter bilden
die temperaturen liegen morgens zwischen
11 und 26 grad und am sonntag geht es
ganz ähnlich weiter schönen abend noch